it really is with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may have to take
each other and view
[Music]
hello and welcome to the plate
forget flash cars and designer labels
today's billionaires really have to push
the yacht out when it comes to
impressing potential life partners and
there's one money man who's going to
infinity and beyond to bag himself a bit
of arm candy fashion billionaire yuusaku
Misawa announced this week he's looking
for special someone to join him as he
becomes the first private passenger to
fly to the moon prospective candidates
must be age 20 or over have a bright
personality always be positive enjoy
life to the fullest
and above all be someone who wishes for
world peace there was only one name that
speaks my mind
[Music]
applications close at the end of this
week so Carol I've already filled in the
form for you and had a quiet wording
I've got you on the shortlist I'm
feeling you might be gone for a long
time we've missed the rocket band give
us away from space and and don't miss me
too much
coming up on the program Cowell says so
long to Harry and Megan I haven't got
hopes for the high street June says we
need to end the stigma around adoption
and Andrew is ringing the bell for
brexit the first is Maggie
move over Isis according to
counterterrorism policing there are a
new bunch of extremists on the block
extinction rebellion well at least for a
brief period this week CT police
southeast had placed XR on par with Isis
extremists and banned neo-nazi terror
groups in a brochure that they
distributed as part of their prevent
program the police's decision now
appears to have been revoked after
repeated press inquiries good now
alongside organizing Hitler and bad
daddy
police had advised readers to watch for
those who commit such dangerous acts as
speaking strong or emotive terms about
environmental issues like climate change
or pollution and Banksy be we're writing
environmentally themed graffiti was also
noted as a sign of danger now look I'm
aware there are some who think XR
activists are seeking to exploit the
environments and mass mobilize against
captain's but still prevent does some
good and is do a review perhaps as parts
of this review someone should ask what
sorts of process allows placing a bunch
of tree huggers alongside terrorist
groups on officially distributed police
brochures in the first instance
[Music]
it kind of disturbs me that you link
extremism with terrorism because I think
they're they're two different things
oh I don't what you just did you just
said you just said though like Isis you
know you know that the policy the policy
exchanged think-tank produced a report
last year and lifted the lid on the true
motives behind extension rebellion and
their agenda goes way beyond to climate
change as I'm sure you know their their
ideology is rooted in open rebellion
against the government and in political
extremism of anarchism and and anti
capitalism you know that and we've seen
that in action and I think I think
they've can't a lot of people into
believing they are as you just described
them as tree huggers they're way more
than tree huggers let me let me give you
the government's definition of what they
say extremism is it says quote vocal or
active opposition to our shared values
which include democracy and the rule of
law beliefs and actions that fall
outside the mainstream or moderate
values and I think you would have to say
that extinction rebellion absolutely
fits into that category so but the
government doesn't really just cited the
government definition I'm a bit confused
because there are many things to
criticize about extinction
no it doesn't agree with applying the
definition on to extinction rebellion as
we're here in a second from Preeti Patel
the Home Secretary but IIIi don't
dispute there are many things to
criticize extinction rebellion over the
question is whether Carol and I hope you
agree with me the question is surely
they should not have been listed under
the government's prevent by well let's
just quickly bring Preeti Patel the home
century before you come back on that
question as well right so because she
doesn't agree with what you just said
there here itself then obviously you
know protest organization but everything
has to be based in terms of West to the
public security rest security threat and
it's based on information from the peace
and know various intelligence that we
all receive it's a protest group not a
terror group isn't it yes we call him
he's not on the show
terror and extreme scrim however I mean
I'll pick you up well you said that not
Dennis last year they said that we're
gonna they were gonna stop planes flying
out of he threw and they were gonna do
that by using drones and they said if
they didn't get their own way on day one
they were do it for ten ten days after
that now that is a danger to public
safety and don't tell me it's not and
also they they advocate mass public
disruption I think you know people
people listen let me finish this point
and then you can all come people have
except mass law breaking and then
liberal democracy to further a political
cause that's extremist in my view June
I'll be quick all I'll say is nobody
would deny that they are disruptive I
know I was having to go into the office
on many days where they were protesting
and it was incredibly annoying as a
commuter but up until this point all of
their protests have been peaceful
they've been singing and dancing and
partying I mean I'm not saying I agree
with it but to even lump them in the
same sentence as an Isis makes no sense
whatsoever and quickly before you come
in Andrew I just want to bring in a
statement from Amnesty International's
Kerry Moscow Guri and what she says is
it's deeply shocking that the police
ever seriously considered classifying
peaceful climate crisis protesters as
extreme let me finish to see that
schoolchildren were effectively going to
be profiled under these proposed
measures just deepens our shock given
that children are potentially those who
will be most affected by the climate
emergency it's vital that they are able
to speak out on these issues without
this heavy-handed and entirely
disproportionate police attention what
is lawful about shoving the great big
plastic boat in the middle of Oxford
City every Highway rule under the Sun
and the police know it and the police
turned a blind eye to and it was
appalling the way they allowed these
people to completely hold our capital
city to economic ransom exactly when
they did it once I think people were
okay they've done it once they've raised
it that the agenda they've raised the
issue high up the political agenda but
to keep repeating it to try and block
the access road into Gatwick Airport
disrupting people's flights that is
economic
that is extreme the government down a
terrorist no I how big a grouping do you
want to the more you include in the same
as I include this laughs you've got into
a guy there's a guy who was a policeman
a former Chief Superintendent who is now
a member of extinction rebellion he is
called Rob Cooper his worth isn't it
extinction rebellion phoned the police
tell the police what's going to happen
they turn up in huge numbers they turn
up with a big bright pink boat or a pink
bathtub and of course when somebody from
a an oil company says that you know
sixteen-year-old schoolgirl from Sweden
is the enemy then you clearly know the
message is getting through I mean
anybody who was affected by them when
they're in London to some extent and we
all I mean there was a bit of us all
quite like the guy got off top of the
tube train and through him I said look
I've gotta go I've been there I have to
bring in counterterrorism police South
East who listed station rebellion
because they've admitted their mistake
and this is what they had to say they
said we do not classify extinction
rebellion as an extremist organization
the inclusion of extinction rebellion in
this document was an error of judgments
and we will now be reviewing all of the
contents as a result we as
counterterrorism policing have a
responsibility to protect vulnerable
people officers are trained to spot
those who may be vulnerable and the
membership of an organization that
supports environmental or animal wear
for welfare issues would not be a
trigger so as a result of me reading
that the question I was going to ask you
is I'm a bit confused as to what exactly
it is you're arguing because I'm not
disputing with you that a extension
rebellion have disruptive they're
frustrating they know I'm asking you
thought my question is should they have
been listed as under the prevent
guidance alongside Isis and neo-nazi
terrorists when the police say
no and they made a mistake in the home
setters saying okay are you saying yes
yes I am I've answered this question the
think tank who looked into this
organization which the police haven't
actually the police are talking about
what they saw on the street there this
they say extinction rebellion as an
extremist organization whose methods
need to be confronted and challenged
rather than supported and condoned
if we fail to confront those who incite
and encourage mass law-breaking which
they did we fail in our duty to confront
extremism this new form of extremism
needs to be tackled by ministers
politicians and the Commission for
countering extremism that's this is some
people who've looked into them their
aims and their ideology and they have
concluded that their views are extreme
no that's not the point Carol nobody is
disputing all of the issues around
extension rebellion in terms of their
disruptive approaches I'm not talking
about or talking about the policy
exchange have nots in one of the
sentences that you read the auditor
recommended that they should be added to
the list or even compare them to Isis in
any way shape or form and I think that
actually we have to be very careful when
we start conflating the two you are
actually diluting the danger and the
terror that an Isis imposes to us let's
not even put them in the same sentences
at all it's a completely different give
them a nice set you can even say you
think they're extreme but they should
not be in any pamphlet that lumps them
together my field terror organizing I
think what do you encourage mass law
breaking in the liberal democracy but
there are encourage whose income they're
encouraging people to join them that's
what they're doing they're encouraging
people their courage civil disobedience
school age